hello ladles and jelly spoons I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report and
you're watching on YouTube so we got to
get to it quick
I've got Aaron Foley I've got fred
Karger and I've got Kelly Carlin and we
are starting off with clearly the most
important story of the year the Oscars
let's get to it
general feelings to start Aaron what you
thought sure I think I've ever seen I've
watched it four times today I know it
was that was a stink bomb a good thing I
was drunk no it was a there was a couple
ones I thought Seth maybe I thought it
one every 25 jokes worked and then at
the very end he's like thanks for
staying it's been the longest show ever
then I'm gonna do another number because
the show was about him alright so yeah
Chuck Aaron Foley up is unimpressed fred
Karger
what did you think I have to agree and I
love the Oscars I used to go to the
Oscars I said many hearts you're gonna
do holding Oscars with stars you're
always holding them very tight and the
Oscar in another hand I used to crash
the Oscar ended up on stage a couple
years but it was a different era they
had better shows last nights I think
they were trying to are they're making a
big effort for this younger demographic
which I guess they got according to the
Nielsen's today but I think they really
missed the boat and Seth should should
continue writing and I think let's get
Billy Crystal or Eddie Murphy or a
couple a comedian who can respond to the
what's happening at the show that was
missing yeah because when you want young
people Billy Crystal
what comes to mind Kelly Carlin what did
you think
or Shirley Bassey and Barbra Streisand
I'm still confused about what the cast
of Chicago has to do with anything
I'm I'm just dumbfounded every time
they'd show up I'm like what they're
here again what's going on I was
confused the whole time I just kept
writing on Twitter confused I'm confused
again what's going on it seemed it
seemed like a big Mis mishmash stuff
just a lot of food Stewart was
definitely confused
I didn't watch the red carpet and I
don't know I'm not on my Kristen Stewart
Twitter feed every two seconds so I know
I did she cut her foot the first time
you see her she's she's hobbling out
she's like a bruised arm or Harrah's
lolly I was like what did she just bang
a cameraman right before she went
onstage like what is happening she looks
like a hot mess yeah is it harder for a
woman you think because we're so focused
you know I know looks for the way the
guys can come out and all these
ridiculous beards in there there's all
this the women have to look so perfect
yeah they're either boys a snore you're
either too skinny or you're too fast
yeah in this town and there's a lot of
skinny girls out there and so a lot of
things was you know feed this girl feed
this girl I I can't even imagine it's
it's impossible standards you're screwed
either way I just walk properly and not
look completely blazing high yeah I mean
it's we got a high bar for her we
confirmed that she wasn't high because I
didn't realize the ankle thing either
and she looked like she had just done
drugs stumbled out and then my favorite
moment was when Jennifer Lawrence
tripped I do yes real moment thank you
yeah she handled herself so well this
was a joking around and yeah she was
awesome she's cool what do you guys
think of the idea that the host can sort
of never win because pretty much exactly
what you all said that you know no
matter how good he is you're gonna get
the snark on Twitter of course and
people are gonna go crazy now you're the
non comedian at the table so as a
regular citizen which is how we refer to
not yes as a regular citizen of the
United States what do you think for the
host is it is it an unwinnable
proposition basically but I think they
had the Biggest Loser last night and
Seth and and I don't mean to criticize
him just for that but but it was it was
poorly done on his part and the writing
was terrible where was Bruce Vilanch
where were those jokes when when there
was a trip onstage you're supposed to
come and respond to that trip there was
not one mention of anything that
happened in the show was all scripted I
think Seth MacFarlane could have just
taped that thing a week ago and and
phoned it in and that was missing yeah I
think they need to get the Pixar writers
because the Pixar writers have a way of
writing jokes for like the grown-ups in
a Thea
and at the same time the kids and it's
the same thing with the Oscars you have
to please the insider Hollywood crowd
and you have to please 10 billion people
watching around the world so there's I
know it can be done and it has some
years but and I'd said McFarland very
funny extremely talented human beings it
just wasn't funny I wasn't laughing sock
puppets were like super talented super
funny I just thought some of it it is
it's about pleasing the masses and he
just it was so specific of just like
snark Ville and pushing the envelope and
it that doesn't really work for Oscars
you have to please like my parents
speaking of classy and this constant
need to please do you think there's
something weird about how when they do
something a little edgy if you can call
a Lincoln joke about being assassinated
150 years ago edgy but it's somehow that
the these elite liberals are seem to be
the most offended people even though
they're supposed to have the best sense
of humor what's the deal with that you
Republican I was curious along the
Lincoln assassination lines everybody
was sitting in the boxes seemed to win
that you notice that so I don't know I
think next year you're gonna have
people's you know insisting celebrities
nominator gonna be insisting they sit in
one of those boxes or they're not coming
to they never saw anyone sit in the
balcony before this year was that it
without a nod to Lincoln what was it and
don't forget bonobos comm is the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
enter code Reuben report for 20% off
your first purchase